Alex dealer with a gamespot news update
what's better than a fallout collection
Apollo collection you can store and your
very own mini new during the opening
ceremony for quakecon 2015 today
Bethesda marketing boss Pete Hines
announced a new follower collection
coming this year prior to the launch of
fallout 4 called the fallout anthology
this PC collection brings together 5
Fallout games fallout Fallout to follow
our tactics fallout 3 game of the year
edition and follow new vegas ultimate
edition better yet the fallout anthology
comes inside of a mini nuke that
features a special bomb sound effect but
that's it didn't exactly share how big
the replica bomb is but it's large
enough to house six games the sixth spot
being a place to store your fallout 4
disc once it's released in November 10
the fifty-dollar followed an apology
will go on sale in North America on sep
tember 29th in australia on october
first and in europe on october second
for more follow news check back on
gamespot com